These are the 10 least reliable vehicles of the year
according to Consumer Reports.
Reliability is scored from one to a hundred,
with 1 hundred being the best.
Let's see how many of these surprise you.
Starting off at No. 10 is the Jeep Wrangler
with a score of 27.
No. 9, the Jeep Grand Cherokee
with a score of 26.
No. 8, we've got the Volkswagen Jetta with a score of 25.
No. 7, we've got our first truck scored at 23,
the Nissan Frontier.
No. 6, another Jeep,
the Grand Cherokee L,
also with a score of 23.
In the middle of the pack at No. 5 with a score of 22,
is the Rivian R1T,
followed by the Volvo XC60 at No. 4 with a score of 21.
Now No. 3, this one surprised me a bit.
I've honestly heard mostly good things about these,
so if you drive one of these,
I'd love to hear your opinion on it.
No. 3 is the Ford F ONE FIFTY Hybrid,
and it scored at nineteen.
No.2 is the Volkswagen Taos with a score of 18.
Which brings us to the least reliable vehicle
according to Consumer Reports.
Coming in at No. 1 is the Chrysler Pacifica Hybrid
with a score of fourteen.